Astronomie teams haben jetzt ein objekt in 20 lichtjahren entfernung entdeckt das weltweit große rätsel aufgibt denn es ist eine art grenzgänger und
steht genau auf der grenze zwischen stern und planet es ist deutlich schwerer als der jupiter aber nur knapp größer zudem hat es
polarlichter und ein äußerst starkes magnetfeld also wirklich ziemlich mysteriöse eigenschaften die so eigentlich nicht zusammenpassen
was steckt hinter dem geheimnisvollen objekt tricks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das jetzt entdeckte objekt mit der bezeichnung
spj
01 36 5 663 +0 93 34 73
ist ein wirklich besonderer weise äußerst mysteriös eigentlich endet es einen braunen zwerg
aber dann doch nicht in unserer milchstraße könnte es 100 milliarden stück von diesen braunen zwergen geben sie zeichnen sich dadurch aus
dass sie zu kalt und zu klein sind um echte sterne mit anhaltender
kernfusion zu werden
auf der anderen seite sind sie aber auch zu groß und zu warm um als planet durchgehend zu können oft werden diese objekte deswegen als
gescheiterte sterne bezeichnet auch in direkter nachbarschaft zur erde existieren solche braunen zwerge
beispielsweise umkreisen sich nur 6,6 lichtjahre von uns entfernt
gleich zwei braune zwerge doch das jetzt entdeckte objekt ist anders entdeckt wurde es von einem astronomie team aus kalifornien
sie hatten es mit
radioteleskope des very large array
beobachtet und gleich festgestellt dass es für einen braunen zwerg eigentlich zu klein und zu leicht ist hier jetzt
seine konkreten daten im vergleich zum jupiter dem größten planeten des sonnensystems das mysteriöse objekt ist rund
12,7 jupitermassen schwer doch die grenze ab der eine delhi um kernfusion möglich ist und ein objekt als brauner zwerg bezeichnet werden kann
liegt bei 13 jupitermassen und so liegt das objekt knapp darunter zudem ist das objekt auch mit seinen 825
grad auch nicht heiß genug für einen braunen zwerg das forschungsteam schätzt den mysteriösen himmelskörper auf jugendliche 200 millionen jahre
diese fakten lassen also eher darauf schließen dass es sich um einen riesigen planeten
infrage kommen unter diesen umständen nur sogenannte einzelgänger planeten das sind
gasriesen die alleine durch das all wandern und eben nicht um einen stern kreisen bisher geht man davon aus dass solche
einzelgänger planeten entweder ähnlich wie sterne entstanden sind nämlich durch den kollaps von gaswolken
als eine andere möglichkeit ihrer entstehung werden turbulenzen angesehen die die objekte aus ihrem heimatplaneten system ins all
geschleudert haben zu all diesen rätseln kommen zwei weitere seltsame beobachtungen hinzu der mysteriöse himmelskörper hat ein gigantisches
magnetfeld etwa
200 mal stärker als das vom jupiter dazu schreibt das forschungsteam aus
kalifornien zitat die kombination von alter masse und temperatur dieses himmelskörpers kann ein so starkes magnetfeld nicht erklären
doch wie kommt es dann zu stande eine vermutung ist nun dass das objekt eine extrem schnelle rotation
besitzt was zudem weitere rätsel aufgibt der grenz läufer hat auch
polarlichter wie kann das sein schließlich gibt es in seiner nähe keine sterne und somit auch keine
sonnenwinde die diese leuchte erscheinung durch eine interaktion mit dem magnetfeld erklären könnten
eine erklärung könnte sein dass das objekt einen planeten oder mond besitzt der in wechselwirkung mit dem magnetfeld des mysteriösen objekts
polarlichter auslöst ähnlich passiert dies beim saturn und seinem mund m namens enceladus
vorstellbar wäre aber auch dass die polarlichter durch
wechselwirkungen innerhalb der atmosphäre des objekts entstehen so ist es bei einigen polarlichtern des jupiters der fall auf die große frage
planet oder brauner zwerg haben die astronomie teams bisher keine eindeutige antwort geben können
dennoch wurde das objekt bereits in eine gruppe eingeordnet und zwar in die spektral klasse c
2.5 darin befinden sich braune riesen die in ihren spektralen signaturen
hinweise auf methan was sagt kohlenmonoxid aber auch natrium und kalium
in ihren atmosphären haben das forschungsteam aus kalifornien ist sich sicher schon bald mehr über
dieses objekt zu wissen das könnte dann wiederum dabei helfen die magnetischen prozesse bei sternen und planeten besser zu verstehen
das sagt eine beteiligten forscherinnen
melodika ab sofort könnt ihr auch bei pixum mitglied werden für einen monatlichen betrag bekommt ihr neben ein paar
privilegien ein extra video und einen extra live stream nur für euch einfach hier unten auf
mitglied werden klicken und wenn er kein video zum thema astronomie zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und werdet sogar vorab über neue videos informiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren dafür hier kriegen aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken erste aufzeichnung einer supernovaexplosion
bis dann
bleibt dran